[Music]
have you ever considered why you're here
while you're watching this video among
the millions of others churning across
the internet did you by your own free
will choose to click or was it an
algorithm spooning it to you convincing
you that you had a choice a manipulation
giving you the illusion of control would
you know could you tell the difference
where does free will end and the
invisible hand begin ask yourself who
chose this you
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show where today it's time to make
owo the commenter into owo the commented
on
hi yes hello head editor dan here as you
could tell matt doesn't know how to say
oh whoa so on behalf of matt and all of
team theorist i apologize for matt's
dadness okay back to the theory
now for anyone who's taken a look down
in the comments section of our videos
over the last couple months chances are
you already know just how often you can
find the account owo heck they've been
commenting on a bunch of game theory
videos starting back on april 17th this
year at least as far as i can tell and
that's great thank you owo in fact thank
you to everyone down there who comments
each and every week i know it's kind of
a thing that youtubers don't like
reading their comments and yeah i went
through that phase two where it was kind
of a scary place to be but now i don't
know things have changed for me maybe
i'm just more confident now maybe it's
that the comments have gotten nicer but
overall it's just really great getting
to see what your thoughts are in fact
some of our best episode suggestions
these days come from the comments and
i've been trying to make more theories
with you commenters in mind like over on
food theory where we're testing out your
burger recipes supplied to us via the
reddit and the comments so if you ever
want to say anything long or short smart
or dumb whatever just drop us a line
down there we do read them and to the
theorist out there type in an ironic
comment about how you doubt i'll read
yours i have read it your username is
very funny thank you very much but owo
was a commenter who caught my attention
not just because they have highly liked
comments on a lot of our videos but
because they aren't just commenting on
our videos owo seems to be everywhere
you can find them having top comments on
videos from markiplier dan tdm
technoblade tons of others video after
video and they don't stop there we found
owo had left comments on channels with
just eight subs starlight shiner who
made a fun little video to let us know
that owo is a friend at first i thought
the account must just be a bot spamming
the comment section of popular youtube
videos for attention but the content of
their comments suggests that they're
actually watching the videos not just
pulling from the titles and descriptions
something abot just wouldn't be capable
of so it's a person who comments a lot
on youtube what's the big deal why am i
dedicating a full video let alone a full
theory video to one random commenter in
the sea of millions of youtube viewers
out there well it's because owo isn't
everything they seem to be they're not
just a funny and omnipresent commenter
across the platform go to their channel
and you immediately discover something
much more sinister going on hidden in
their content is an arg that involves a
mysterious government agency glitchy
tapes with hidden messages something
dark that lurks in the shadows and a
not-so-subtle message from the channel's
creator that all these videos connect to
something much much larger owo is the
sort of mystery most of you in the
comments section have overlooked because
it's hiding in the best place among you
in plain sight amidst a sea of other
anonymous commenters so today we're
going to start to crack open what that
mystery seems to be and reveal to you
the entity that you've unknowingly been
sharing the comment section with this
entire time let's start where my journey
began the owo channel itself as i
mentioned before what initially set me
down this path was seeing owo appear in
video after video after video on our
channel top comment after top comment at
a certain point i was like hey gotta go
check this person out and immediately i
was taken aback 188 000 total
subscribers with only three videos now
i'm intrigued i mean that is fantastic
performance which means that those
videos must be pretty darn good right
well what hid in that 4 minutes and 32
seconds of content was not what i
expected the first video soon is pretty
basic acting as our introduction to the
series and owo the character we're
presented with an explicit warning about
owo claiming that they haunt quote the
comment section all over the platform
and if we see them don't encounter it as
it's absolutely everywhere the camera
zooms out from a stock 1970s tv and we
cut to a view from behind it as a door
opens and owo walks in he turns the tv
off and rests his head against it like
he's exhausted looks up and notices a
camera with a note that reads as follows
dear owo please for the sake of your
family please upload a video like it has
been a hundred years just back to us
please sincerely some people just before
the video ends we see a flash of the
word soon now this at first seems like
it would just be a simple subscriber
update style video a creator teasing to
the audience that an upload is coming in
the near future but there's actually a
lot of information that we can
immediately pull from this first the
warning at the beginning calls owo and
it giving us the sense that this isn't a
person or at least not a person in the
traditional sense secondly the note says
for the sake of your family which means
that owo has been separated from its
loved ones in some way and maybe they're
looking for a sign that owo is safe
maybe owo has been captured or maybe is
in hiding in some way the next reference
to 100 years also tells us that wherever
owo is they've been gone for a long time
and lastly we can narrow down when the
video was recorded based on the model of
the camera a canon eos 1500d this camera
was unveiled on february 25th 2018 so
the video must have been recorded
sometime after that date the second
video cookie released five months later
again starts with a warning warning the
following animation you're about to
watch contains disturbing images not
suitable for the viewer this footage is
heavily protected by the agency as it's
used for information purposes only
viewer discretion advised after some
flashing which some have guessed his
morse code but when we tested didn't
seem to spell anything we get more
glitchy text and learn that this is file
number two titled beginning smaller text
at the bottom reads privacy act of 1974.
if you look carefully you can see owo
silhouette flash behind the glitchy text
in this moment so all of this seems to
support those clues from the first video
the references to a mysterious agency
the privacy act the explicit warnings
put in front of the video it seems like
these are videos that are
owned that owo may have been captured by
some secret agency where it's been
imprisoned for a long time maybe as the
subject of some tests and now the videos
are being released to the public if we
keep watching we start to get some
answers during the video owo claims that
someone is looking for them i carry this
myself yet because they're looking for
me which means that the video was
released before owo was captured and
they can't tell us who they are but give
us a symbol to remember their presence
what could it be some creepy scp logo
satanic imagery a coded maze nope owo
gives us a cookie saying that whenever
you think of this i'm still around life
well that is not what i expected you
have this dark noir setting with creepy
glitches and you give us a cookie at
least it's chocolate chip and not some
reject cookie like snickerdoodle anyway
the video ends with someone breaking
into owo's location we get some final
flashes and the messages the video will
end shortly help me please i'll be back
in the final video 100k released april
17th 2021 ow gets a letter from an
anonymous person congratulating them for
hitting 100k subs owo calls out that the
number reads like look after some more
static and glitching we see that this
video is file 6 titled strange milestone
the file naming seems to be setting up a
timeline of events so far with only
files two and six revealed a timer shows
up on the screen and owo fades in as a
creepy face looms behind him after
celebrating his milestone achievement
owo realizes that the whole thing has
been a trap but it's too late the timer
hits 60 seconds the screen flashes
revealing the creepy face with the
message i found you and the video
abruptly ends putting all the clues
across all three videos together it
seems that owo is an entity that was
hunted and captured by a government
agency after making a mistake and
recording a video for longer than 60
seconds except we're clearly missing
something that's critical to the story
why why owo who or maybe better what is
owo to make it such a hunted entity well
with a name like the commenter you'd
expect that their comments are a large
part of what we need to analyze to try
and solve things and from looking
through the comments we can actually
learn a bunch of things about owo the
oldest comment that we could find was on
the unspeakable gaming channel back on
october 25th 2019. but since owo
officially joined youtube on may 1st
2019 there may be some others that
predate that one that we weren't able to
find we also know that ow's birthday is
on may 18th important to note since
that's the record date hinted at in the
second video that they grew up addicted
to cartoons that they're a cat person
and that at some point owo's father left
but that is a small percentage of their
online comments if floor is truly hiding
in the place owo is most known i have to
get to work especially when you take
into account the fact that according to
an interview with owo on the subreddit
find owo they spend anywhere between 6
and 12 hours a day commenting on videos
assuming that owo moves slowly and
watches each video in its entirety that
would average one video every say 11.7
minutes giving them the generous
estimate of two minutes to type a
comment owo could be leaving nearly 53
comments over a 12-hour day on the low
end with his account active for 817 days
as of writing the script they may have
left in the range of 43
301 comments oh my god
what have i done is what i would be
saying had it not been for owo actually
posting on reddit that quote commenting
has nothing to do with the arg at all
this also apparently applies to owo's
second channel as well dark revolution
which is quote again just a channel to
post fun content in it has no relation
to anything with the arg which means i
don't have to go through 40 000 comments
or an additional channel's worth of
videos to solve this thing looks like
christmas came early for old matpat this
year so with no other videos our last
source of information is from owo's
community section there are nine total
posts here some are owo seemingly
messing around but there are also two
previews of videos coming down the road
with hints to the airg they both have
one thing in common the reappearance of
that creepy face in one the face is
inside a tv behind a silhouetted man in
a suit possibly hinting that the creepy
face is behind the government who's
controlling what we see the second has
the creepy face on a billboard behind
the word message which again could be
taken as the creepy face literally being
in control over the media or the imagery
that we see in the world around us so
okay owo seems to be being hunted and
tested on by a government agency that
can seemingly control the media so again
what is owo and why does it matter well
dear theorists get your pepe silvia
boards out and strap in we're about to
sail dangerously close to 10-foot tall
wario territory i believe that owo
is a meme a meme that has come to life
now this seems insane with so little
information to go on but hear me out
here there has to be a reason for the
agency to need owo an agency that again
based on the community post seems to be
able to control and manipulate the media
well owo must be able to do or be able
to offer this agency something that they
don't currently have which had me coming
back to the first warning on the first
video warning this message is about a
mysterious person who haunts the comment
sections all over the platform if you
see a humanoid figure please don't
encounter it as it's absolutely
everywhere well what relates to the
media spreads like a virus and can
change the way that people think memes
in fact when the word and concept of a
meme was first proposed back in 1976 it
was literally compared to a parasite for
the brain to quote from evolutionary
biologist richard dawkins in his book
the selfish gene from 1976 quote when
you plant a fertile meme in the mind you
literally parasitize my brain turning it
into a vehicle for the meme's
propagation in just the way that a virus
might parasitize the genetic mechanism
of a host cell what if owo the commenter
is the original concept of a meme come
to life and embodied in one single
humanoid entity if the agency knows that
owo is some kind of ultimate meme then
trying to limit owo's power by warning
people to avoid contact with it makes
absolute sense i mean across the last
few presidential elections we've seen
the power that memes can wield so to a
government they could be seen as a
threat capturing owo suddenly makes
sense as the ability to control an
entity with the potential to influence
human behavior and cultural evolution
would give them incredible levels of
power or they could just keep that power
from others owo's very first action in
this series is to rest his head against
a television intended to be from the
1970s this same decade that dawkins
published the selfish gene that could
absolutely be a coincidence but when you
google image search for 1976 vintage tv
the same tv used in owo's video shows up
right near the top of the search results
for sure it is absolutely a stretch but
it's also an arg so it's not wrong to
consider anything a possible clue but
the biggest hint to me goes back to the
cookie from the second video like why a
cookie it makes no sense is it meant to
be like lol random funny or maybe the
cookie isn't a cookie consider this if
owo is some kind of internet-based
entity come to life it wouldn't be
far-fetched to assume that the cookie is
a computer cookie for anyone that
doesn't know a computer cookie or an
http cookie is a small block of data
placed on your computer by a website at
their most benign they're used to track
your internet activities at their worst
well let me tell you a story back in
2005 a hacker named sami kamkar alias js
space hero created a computer worm on
myspace which for all of you youngans
was the older even less cool version of
facebook anyway sami's worm was intended
as a prank and it made it so anyone who
visited his page would automatically add
him as a friend and their profile would
then display the message but most of all
sammy is my hero it also added that code
to any infected profile within 20 hours
sammy's message was on over a million
profiles making it the single fastest
spreading virus of all time his message
not unlike owo seemed to be everywhere
but sammy's love of computers didn't end
after he created the single fastest
spreading virus of all time among a ton
of other interesting projects he created
something known as the ever cookie ever
cookie is a cookie that identifies and
reproduces itself intentionally when
it's deleted this ability to respawn is
so good that in 2013 when edward snowden
released top secret nsa documents we
learned that they had been using
evercookie to track users now do i think
that owo and its cookie symbol are based
on the story of a single hacker who
happened to create something co-opted by
a us government agency for its own use
no but the general idea of it all fits
an entity that spreads virality and
can't be deleted represented by a cookie
one that is used for near-omniscient
tracking abilities one that was used by
shadowy government agencies the
similarities between these stories do
seem to be very interesting so is that
it is owo really just the living
embodiment of a meme captured by a
government agency attempting to gain
more power and influence with plans to
ultimately control culture and society
as a whole looks like we'll have to wait
for a few more pieces to put the puzzle
together and i guarantee someone will be
watching us from the shadows and from
the comments i'll see you down below owo
make sure the rest of you down there say
hi to him we don't want to be impolite
and most importantly of all remember
it's all just a theory a film theory and
cuts
hi it's me again back for the end card
thank you so much for watching you can
click on this here
and i'll take you somewhere and you
click here
that'll take you somewhere
i don't know where i'm sure it'll be
exciting
you don't need to sit and wait for
for me i'll see you there
leave